In the SCP system, uncontained anomalies are
considered especially heinous.
At the SCP Foundation, the dedicated operatives
who investigate and neutralize these deadly
aberrations are members of elite, specialized
squads known as Mobile Task Forces.
These are their stories.
Dun dun.
Hey, that was pretty good.
Someone should make a TV show about this.
But I digress.
MTF’s are a vital part of what keeps the
SCP Foundation up and running, and keeps the
public safe from all kinds of dangerous anomalies.
MTF’s specialize in a wide variety of different
threats and can be dispatched to handle those
threats when ordinary field operatives just
won’t do.
They might be a large army of militarized
on-the-ground forces, or a tiny group of highly
qualified researchers.
It all depends on their specialty, and what
sorts of threats the task force exists to
handle.
Either way, they represent the best of the
best that the Foundation has to offer.
If given the opportunity to join one of these
oh-so-exclusive task forces, which would you
choose and why?
We posed this question to our loyal viewers
here at SCP Explained, and received as wide
and varied a number of responses as the MTF’s
themselves.
So, without further ado, let’s get into
it and see who’s suiting up for battle,
brushing up on their thaumatology, or trying
to crack down on that pesky Dr. Bright once
and for all.
[ANIMATION: Dr. Bright runs away, grinning,
while being chased by MTF Members.]
Luna Heartnet said, “Beta-7, Maz-Hatters.
The cleanup and containment of biohazardous
anomalies sound like grueling work, mentally
and physically, but it also lines up pretty
well with my real-world skill set.”
Listen, one of the most important parts of
job-hunting is knowing your strengths!
If your strength lies with cleaning up all
kinds of supernatural gunk, goo, and slime,
then more power to you!
Grab a department-issued super-mop and get
down to it.
Thank you for your service, a clean Foundation
is an effective Foundation.
Iron Clamp said, “Mu-13 “Ghostbusters”.
Everyone knows how scary fighting the SCPs
that you can actually see and physically deal
with are.
But imagine the steel balls it takes to go
into a scene to deal with a potentially deadly
SCP that you can’t do either of those things
with.
It would be like a much more violent version
of Paranormal Activity or Insidious but instead
you have to figure out how to deal with it.
Also the idea of “Ghostbusters But With
Guns!” is just too good for me to pass.”
Sounds like you’re a horror fan, so enjoy
your own personal entry into the Paranormal
Activity Extended Universe and try your best
not to become a ghost yourself.
Who ya gonna call?
Yanooska_A1 said, “I would definitely want
to be a member of Epsilon-11 “Nine Tailed
Fox”.
The fact that they’re only called in to
deal with a facility that has gone to complete
shit, and in such small teams proves that
the skill set of these troops Is astonishing.
Not to mention they’re under the command
of Alpha-1 “Red right hand”, who are known
as the best of the best.
Also probing their skills in the game SCP:
Containment Breach, where three troops are
sent into a facility where some of the most
infamous SCPs have breached, such as SCP-173,
SCP-049, SCP-106 and many more.
They easily sweep through the facility, with
no casualties.
So in my opinion, Epsilon-11 would be my go
to Task Force.”
You’ve definitely got your work cut out
for you if you want to become a member of
Episolon-11 and serve the Red right hand,
but if you can hold your own against the likes
of the Sculpture , the Old Man , and the Plague
Doctor , then go right ahead and try!
I hope you’ve got quick reflexes, an itchy
trigger finger, and can go hours without blinking.
RiftZ said, “I'd proudly wear the insignia
of MTF Eta-10 "See No Evil".
I think visual cognitohazards is a really
interesting thing to work with.”
Interesting, sure, and extremely dangerous
too!
Good job knowing what you want, and knowing
that what you want is to risk exposure to
all kinds of things that’ll make it impossible
to trust your own eyes.
Don’t worry, we’ve heard working with
Eta-10 is a lot like a game of Marco, Polo!
Only if you get it wrong, you break your brain,
die, and unleash unspeakable destruction on
countless innocent people.
The Drum Major said, “Definitely MTF Alpha-9
"Last Hope" I've always loved the more human/friendly
anomalies and feel that even the more hostile
sentient entities have some sort of kindness
within them that can be shown if given time.
Being able to work along side these friendly
entities to help people would be amazing.”
That’s so sweet!
So instead of just containing anomalies, you’d
like to have them as your coworkers!
It’s a pretty impressive team you’d be
joining, one that includes the likes of Iris
Thompson, SCP-4051 - also known as “Your
Friendly Neighborhood Keter” - and the shadowy
icon of crime-fighting we call The Specter.
But there’s no need to be intimidated, I’m
sure you have your own strengths to bring
to the table too.
Maybe you always get everyone’s coffee order
right, or you’re great at giving pep talks.
Whatever it is, you’ll be a great addition
to the team.
Lemon Demon Danganronpa - hell of a name you
have there - said, “It would be interesting
for me to be part of MTF Omega-9, also known
as the Scrubs.
For context, they are a group of gamers who
got trapped in a lobby of Quake and now help
out the Foundation.
While being stuck in a game would have some
psychological consequences, it would be fun
to 360 no-scope the competition and other
SCPs who dare stand in my way!”
Why settle for being a Twitch streamer or
a professional in the world of e-sports, when
you could just leave your earthly life behind
completely and spend the rest of your days
in a world of pixels and non-stop action?
You’ll miss your friends and family, sure,
but don’t think too hard about that part.
The rest of it sounds pretty poggers.
Do people still say that?
Don’t tell me, I don’t want to know.
TheRagingAtom said, “This isn’t even a
contest.
I’d go with MTF Sigma-3, the Bibliographers.
Of course, not until after the whole library
invasion thing had cooled off and they reorganized.
It’s just the closest you could get in the
foundation to recreational anomalous usage,
which is awesome.
Who knows, maybe I’ll sacrifice everything
I hold dear to become a type blue”
Smart move waiting for the action to cool
off first.
If you end up becoming a type blue, let us
know!
I need a magic act for my nephew’s birthday
party, and he said last year’s Amazing Melvin
pulling a rabbit out of a hat wasn’t cool
enough for his sixth-grade friends.
Mannequin Skywalker said, “Honestly, going
to say MTF Lambda-14 (One-Star reviewers).
I've got a lot of experience in retail, in
many different positions.
So I think I'd fit in there with being able
to tell what seems anomalous or potentially
how to deal with a retail oriented SCP, including...*shudders*
a Karen Class.”
After working in retail, I’m sure you’ve
seen horrors that would put the findings of
the SCP Foundation to shame.
After you’ve dealt with unruly customers
picking a fight about coupons 20 minutes after
closing time, there’s nothing you can’t
handle.
Tor the Jackal said, “I'd go with Zeta-9
"Mole Rats".
I love enclosed spaces, especially those underground.
If given the opportunity I would definitely
join Zeta-9.”
Are you sure you’re not part mole?
Groundhog, maybe?
I’ve never met anyone who “loves” enclosed
spaces, let alone underground ones, but I
also got kicked out of my local spelunking
team for crying too much so maybe that’s
just me.
Sharky Reynolds said, “I'd go for MTF Lambda-5
(White Rabbits), and I would use my training
to determine if the terrible new songs coming
out these days are only popular through reality
warping properties or if the world is doomed
to experience bad taste.”
It’s probably anomalies.
After all, everyone knows that bad music is
a brand new invention and every previous generation
didn’t think the exact same thing about
the new music their kids were listening to.
Hang on, I’m being told that’s absolutely
what happened and that taste is subjective?
Sounds fake.
Besides, there’s got to be a supernatural
explanation for “What Does the Fox Say?”,
I won’t hear otherwise.
BananaOne said, “Zeta-9, "Mole Rats" I gotta
respect this task force since they have the
lowest survival rate when it comes to their
missions.
Besides, I like how their insignia was made
with a design of a gas mask.”
We’ve got another volunteer for the Mole
Rats!
What is it with you guys and dangerous underground
situations?
It’s a cool insignia, sure, but there’s
a reason it’s a gas mask.
You’ll need to wear a GAS MASK.
Good luck to you, I guess.
Nicktwolf discusses said, “For me, it's
kind of a tie between two groups.
I would love to be on MTF Eta-11 ("Savage
Beasts").
I know I'm not 100% deaf and working on learning
sign language.
Being part of a group where I felt like I
belonged and might be excepted would be a
dream come true.
If I couldn't get into there, MTF Sigma-3
("Bibliographers") would be amazing.
The idea of possibly spending time doing research
and gather info in the Library would be a
great experience.
And in possible down time, all of those books
that are waiting to be read.”
That’s a great reason!
The Savage Beasts would be lucky to have you,
and you deserve to work with a team that understands
and appreciates your unique strengths.
Maybe you could split your time between the
two and moonlight as a Bibliographer!
EternalTribute said, “I'd choose Tau-5 "Samsara".
I already feel basically emotionless so it
would have zero impact on me and I like the
idea of immortality and being a cyborg (I
love technology).
However, my alternative would be the Debuggers
or Skynet because I am decent with computers.”
Fabian Roberts said, “MTF Beta-777 ("Hecate's
Spear") Bc I think it’d be interesting to
look for knowledge about the occult rituals
and how to stop them!
Especially in instances where an SCP was involved.”
Specializing in thaumaturgical ritual analysis,
eh?
It’s the closest thing out there to joining
a literal wizard army, so I can see the appeal.
Just be careful, the world of thaumatology
attracts the attention of forces you don’t
want putting a magical target on your back.
Unlike the aforementioned Amazing Melvin,
these guys are doing this stuff for real,
and they’ll do a lot worse than sawing you
in half if you slip up on the job.
Mr.Pixel said, “I would probably want to
be a part of MTF Epsilon-9, the fire eaters.
After all, who can say no to the alluring
destructive power of fire.
And its not a war crime if i roast mostly
anomalous creatures instead of humans.”
For the second time in this video, I say…Are
you okay, buddy?
Maybe you should have a glass of water.
You can’t use it to roast your enemies alive,
but it’ll help you settle down.
https://m.media-amazon.com/images/I/414ZVy9kDVL.jpg]
Nick O’Tein said, “"Skynet" of course.
The internet is a vast ocean containing both
everything and nothing, thus giving me something
to do for the rest of time, or at least until
the world ends.
Plus, what better excuse than being a member
of "Skynet" would I have to watch you guys
all day?”
Now you’re talking!
When you’re not tracking sentient malware
or the influence of the Archon Lord , you
can spend your time watching more videos from
SCP Explained!
That’s the perfect way to unwind after a
long day of scouring the web for old gods
and, I don’t know, an iPhone app that knows
when you’re going to die?
You’re the web expert, not me.
Hey, maybe you could teach me how to make
a TikTok!
Incidentally, we do actually have a TikTok
now at SCPExplainedOfficial.
Go check it out after the video!
Applethree3D said, “Beta 7.
I'm a bio chemist in real life so this would
just go well with my skillsets.
Working with anomalous biohazard clean up
sounds like grueling mental and physical work.”
Didn’t know we had biochemists watching
us!
That’s awesome!
You’re probably overqualified to clean up
biohazardous anomalous material, but dress
for the job you want!
By which I mean, you should probably wear
a HAZMAT suit and some heavy-duty goggles.
Who knows what kind of radioactive slime and
monster snot you’ll be wiping up.
Jei the monk of cherry trees said, “If I
was asked to join any of the MTF teams, most
likely after looking into them, would be:
MTF Theta-4, the Gardeners.
Seeing that many MTF teams usually follow
certain protocols, Gardeners seem to situated
around very flora based SCP's, usually in
sites or locations of known flora based SCP's,
either mitigating the effects, securing or
researching potential ''sprouts'' of SCP's.
Maybe some woodworkers skills might come handy
helping the team.
Though I thoroughly wonder if SCP foundation
would trust a man in a MTF team called Gardeners,
whom has a bonsai plum tree growing from their
head.”
Oh, that’s so nice, you must have a hell
of a green thumb- wait, I’m sorry.
What was that last part?
Bonsai plum tree growing from your head?
For the third, and hopefully final time: Are
you okay?
Blink twice if you’re in danger.
James Harrold said, “Definitely MTF Gamma
13, Asimov's Lawbringers, they're the group
in charge of dealing with Anderson Robotics,
who's the most interesting group outside of
maybe the Church of the Broken God to me.”
Anderson Robotics has been a cybernetic thorn
in the Foundation’s side since 2007, with
influence all throughout the Pacific Northwest
of the United States, as well as branches
in New Mexico, Arizona, and Louisiana.
They’re an elusive group, and while they’re
unlikely to attack the Foundation directly,
their use of science and magic in one mysterious
package is definitely something to keep an
eye on.
Fish Hsif said, “I’d have to go with upsilon
23, art critics.
I’m usually drawing or painting so I’m
down to get my hands dirty dealing with anomalous
art.
And I love sloths”
You like drawing and painting, so naturally,
you’d like to work with anomalous art.
Makes sense.
You might want to steer clear of any art depicting
SCP-2774 though, if you want to continue loving
sloths.
That thing will ruin sloths for you faster
than you can say “Nowhere is safe.
In the corner of my eye, it's just…
Staring…
I don't know, I don't know!”
Charles Watson said, “MTF Eta-5 ("Jäeger
Bombers") sounds exactly like my dream job.
Bombing runs in something like a C-130 is
already something I'm interested in, and getting
to fight what are essentially Kaiju monsters
makes it ten times better.”
Oh.
You said fighting?
Bombing runs?
I grossly misunderstood what Eta-5 is responsible
for.
I’ll just put this bottle of Jägermeister
away and get back to work…
Final Advance said, “MTF Eta-11, Savage
Beasts.
I get triggered by even non anomalous noises
easily so dealing with audio based cognito
hazards where noise discipline and actively
shutting out sounds is perfect for me.”
If you hate sounds, I guess there’s no better
workplace than somewhere where you have to
avoid hearing things at all costs.
You’ll be facing off against trumpets that
can collapse walls, an anomalous chord progression,
and even a corrupted Beatles song, so make
sure you get some really good-quality noise-canceling
headphones though, or you’ll be in for a
rude awakening.
Alexander Berry said, “Bright-99 "oh no
you don't!".
As a way to contain them more efficiently,
I'd have them set up some form of comedic
entertainment to be broadcasted throughout
the foundation to boost morale while keeping
the Bright's entertained.
Of course to be safe we'll keep an eye on
all items they have access to and run the
broadcast through a filter to get rid of possible
cognitohazards.”
“Oh no you don’t” is right!
If you’re a regular viewer of this channel,
or a fan of the designated page on the SCP
wiki, you know that there are more things
Dr. Bright is not allowed to do than there
are things he is.
It’ll take some pretty great comedic entertainment
to keep Bright occupied, I don’t think you
can just throw on Spongebob or Cocomelon and
call it a day.
Dr. Bright is way too attracted to real-life
chaos to be distracted by television, though
it’s a nice enough idea.
Or, wait…are you suggesting we give Dr.
Bright his own tv show?
That’s too much power, you can’t let him
on the airwaves!
He’ll have half the Foundation quacking
like a duck and make the other half’s heads
explode before you can change the channel!
Sorry, your request to join Bright-99 has
been DENIED.
Kirt Gamer said, “I would proudly put the
insignia of MTF Theta-90 In my shoulder knowing
that I have defended humanity, especially
children, from the anomalous mathematics problems.
I will even happily lay down my life to protect
children from trauma, stress, and especially
depression that anomalous math can do I think
math in its entirety is even anomalous, let
us rally together people to ask the 05 council
to contain math entirely due to its anomalous
ability to make anyone cry and be depressed.
I hope my work can bring a smile to the children
that I have defended”
This brought a tear to my eye.
Thank you, Kirt, for your willingness to fight
against the scourge that is simple mathematics.
With your hard work, children all over the
world will never need to hear about Billy
buying 30 watermelons and 22 apples ever again.
Now go check out “SCP Elite Mobile Task
Force Explained” and “SCP Global Occult
Coalition Explained” for more specialized
groups at the SCP Foundation!